i got a call from a source one day
saying there were a bunch of investors
coming into this space and they're
buying amazon businesses
um you know buying them when they're
small and trying to turn them into big
businesses
and the leader of the pack by far is a
company called thracio
what racio does is it acquires amazon
third-party sellers so these are
typically
entrepreneurs maybe they're working out
of a home office they're selling stuff
on amazon
these third-party sellers generate about
60 of amazon's
product sales so they're really the
backbone
of of amazon and you know maybe they're
doing a couple million sales but it's
starting to get too big it's getting
complicated they don't have a big team
they're trying to decide what they
should do with the business and when we
started talking to them what we heard
was just that the complexity of the
ecosystem was so hard
that as a two or three person team
trying to manage
a global supply chain and marketing and
creative and seo and legal
while introducing new products etc etc
it just wasn't something that they could
do
and now companies like brazil have come
along and they've offered to buy these
businesses
um so all of a sudden you're seeing
sellers um cash out they're deciding
okay this is a great
opportunity i'm gonna take an exit i'm
gonna basically become a millionaire as
a basis like what we do
right now and and what we do very well
is we
acquire amazon third-party sellers and
we take those products and we put them
require the products really the brands
and we put them onto our platform and we
grow them we grow them fantastically
nothing works harder or smells more
natural
than angry orange we were able to sort
of create a world in which these
businesses could be bought in a
professional positive way
and in which once we had them we were in
a position to put the right resources in
place to get the right results
it was started in 2018 and it's very
quickly raised over 500 million dollars
it was valued at a billion dollars this
summer
has done 400 million in sales in the
last 12 months
they have about 10 000 items that they
own and sell on amazon
it could be massage guns it could be
hiking poles it could be spatulas
at the end of the day anybody who's in a
consumer product business
lives or dies by whether or not the
consumer likes their product
so if we were thinking about entering a
category what we would do is we would
order the 200 products that are at the
top of the amazon ranking
when we put those products in a room
with four people from our company and
not tell them which ones we were
thinking about or which ones were well
ranked
and let them separate them into piles
and say these are the ones that suck
these are the ones that are pretty good
this one was great i love this one and
essentially we can come out of that mini
focus group with a picture of here's the
three to five
products that genuinely are awesome and
if we
then go back and look at amazon and
discover that not only are these
products
great products but that they rank well
and are well positioned from a
competitive point of view
then it becomes a company that we're
very interested in you know you get
rated based on the quality of how you
how well you manage your supply chain
how will you manage your inventory
that's not something they overly had to
deal with early on right
so now they do and if you score lower
you score more poorly
you pay more for everything damn sorry
i think people also are you know maybe
right to be
a little bit scared of amazon these
companies and
in a way are putting all their eggs in
one basket so if
racio comes along and introduces a
product
it does really well amazon might take
notice it might come out with a copycat
they might undercut it on price maybe
it's higher in the rankings and somebody
clicks on that instead
we're sitting at a moment in time
when the consumer products ecosystem is
changing faster than it ever has
if you designed and built the consumer
products company today you would do it
differently than you did last century
right i mean you do it the way we're
doing it and
a lot of other people are today our
overall objective is to
be a part of this ecosystem and
understand what's happening
well enough to be able to figure out how
the market is going to evolve and what's
going to be important to consumers
faster than
our competitors i think you're going to
see a lot more companies
like thoracio come into the fray all
with the gold by
amazon businesses and scaling them and
so for the consumer i mean that means
that when you go on amazon a lot of
these
products that you're seeing are not
actually going to be owned by mom and
pop
entrepreneurs anymore they're going to
be owned by companies like frasio
that have you know a huge team that is
in charge of marketing and supply chain
and is really bringing
these operations to a new professional
level
you